the world has to and is moving away from
contentbased ver verification uh as as
the paradigm. Um so we're seeing an
increasing shift towards electronic IDs.
Um so think you know portable digital
identities um either from private
issuers or from you know public
government issuers where you're you're
doing a a multi-art verification and
authentication through you know a device
with a pass key that is known to be
possessed by the individual associated
with the identity. Um so you're you
we're really seeing a lot of movement
away from uh contentbased verification
to a lot of device linked um and and
portable digital electronic identity.
[Music]
>> Daniel Flo, thank you so much for
joining me at the human zero day. So
happy to have you here. Thank you.
>> It's a pleasure to be here. Thank you
for having me.
Absolutely. So Daniel, we're here
talking about humans and technology and
identities. You are the head of digital
identity for the London Stock Exchange
Group. Uh seems like not a small
position to be in and quite an
interesting one in today's world.
Digital identities are changing. Um the
way we think about identity is changing
and that's where I want to start. How do
you see the role of digital identity
today and what's happening in the space?
>> Well,
that's a very broad uh question.
>> Um, so I I I I think what I where I
would start is um we're seeing a massive
change in um how our governments, our
authorities uh and our regulators are
viewing digital identity. Um so if you
if you take a step back and look at you
know the 20th century um uh the the
there really wasn't a concept of binding
a digital identity to a physical or a
real world identity that didn't exist
right you had a username you had a
password um and and most of the time if
you needed to open a bank account um or
or or assert your identity in some way
you you went to a brickandmortar ation
uh and a human being looked at your
document and looked at your face uh and
made a determination on the spot. Um
there's a really famous uh Supreme Court
case from the mid1 1990s
um where the US Congress passed a law
requiring age verification for uh adult
content and the the ACLU uh sued and
went to the Supreme Court. Uh, and the
findings in in the case were that there
was effectively no way for someone to
digitally assert their identity at all.
>> Um, and and and the law was struck down
as a result. So, we've we've moved from
a a world where uh the the internet and
our digital selves were maybe like a uh
an accessory um and and and it's it's
become a a world where most of my
transacting uh much of my interacting uh
much of who I am and what I consume and
what I do is done online. Um and our uh
our our infrastructure hasn't kept up.
Um so when we think about digital
identity today, I guess the summary
there is you're really thinking about
workarounds. Um you're taking, you know,
the the the physical ID card you have in
your wallet. That technology was 1915.
Um, the British created the photo ID
because they were worried about German
spies in uh, the first great war. So,
you're taking a 1915 bit of tech, you
are digitizing it with uh a 21st century
bit of tech that you own
um and digitizing your face also with
that userowned piece of technology and
creating this kind of wacky workound uh
for a system that just doesn't reflect
the way that we live our lives today.
>> Wow. So if you actually look at the the
evolution of technology and and if we
look at the two capabilities one of
verifying identities digitally so doing
that matching and then on the other hand
the technologies that are looking to
circumvent these identities. Can you can
you give me a brief overview of even
just the last couple of years what have
we seen sort of in this struggle that
we've been hearing about?
So I mean and and kind of back to that
that concept of a lot of our
verification is is is a workaround,
right? It's almost all contentbased.
>> Yes.
>> So
we're we're we're we're looking at
voice, we're looking at biometrics, and
we're looking at uh physical identity
documents.
>> And all of these are being digitized by
a consumer device owned by that
consumer. Um,
>> so you you have a fundamental
vulnerability
um because you're using content
digitized and produced by hundreds of
millions of consumers across disperate
devices in disparate places uh to to
resolve that identity. And um I I I
would argue that we're already at a
place where no one can trust
usergenerated content without external
validation.
Absolutely. Absolutely. And we and we've
seen uh we've seen somewhat of the
impact of this already. I think that
there were some expectation that there
will be a larger impact especially
surrounding the the recent elections
which which I think is just a a we're
just it will happen. I just think it's a
it's a matter of time. Um, how how are
you see the impact of this inability to
trust digital media translating to the
role of identity verification because we
rely on I this this ability to verify
identities so that we can automate a lot
of these processes like know your
customer as well as you know just simple
logging in to different areas. What's
happening there?
Yeah. So I I think the the world has to
and is moving away from contentbased ver
verification
as as the paradigm. Um so we're seeing
an increasing shift towards electronic
IDs. Um so think you know portable
digital identities um either from
private issuers or from you know public
government issuers where you're you're
doing a a multi-art verification and
authentication through you know a device
with a past key that is known to be
possessed by the individual associated
with the identity. Um, so you're you
we're really seeing a lot of movement
away from uh contentbased verification
to a lot of device linked um and and
portable digital electronic identity
>> and and so seems to me like that's a
really big shift. I mean, we've spent
what it seems to me like the good part
of the last decade or even two decades,
you know, really improving on our
biometric authentication systems to help
reduce the friction. Do you see a world
in which we stop doing that and we go
back to this connection between the
physical and virtual world?
Well, I I I think that the all of this
has always been a workaround because we
did not have that connection between
your physical your your you know your
your meatspace identity and your digital
identity. Um and and what we're seeing
is uh private and public uh options
coming in that offer an authoritative
binding of that physical identity to a
digital identity. Um, so I don't I don't
know that we're I don't think we're
going to move backwards. I think that's
a forward movement. Um, but I think
we're going to get more to, you know,
why does the government only issue you a
physical document? Um, why is the
government not acting as uh the verifier
of my identity on the internet just as
they are when I show up at customs in
Singapore? Um
>> it's just a you know it's just a place
that the government is in the 20th
century uh and you and I are not and
that gap will close. Interesting. And so
you see a world in which governments
come and and look at the workarounds
that we've built as an industry to help
reduce friction and digital interactions
by helping bring they have the the very
they have the source of truth, right?
They are sort of the only ones who have
the source of truth and you're expecting
them to come in and be able to
productize that into digital workflows
whether it's e-commerce websites you
know you know any you know financial
transactions etc and be a part of that
real-time engagement. So I I would say
not not just governments but but
certainly governments is as is one of
them but uh very specifically I'm not
expecting them to they they are um so if
we look at uh at India uh so India
started rolling out ODAR uh in 2009 um
so there's a biometricbased or
devicebound
uh electronic ID that is connected to a
governmentissued real world identity in
India 1.1 billion people use it twice a
month. Um, we look at uh, you know, the
the the elect the bank ID is is the big
electronic ID in the Nordics. Uh, I
think on average uh, Swedish citizens
use it twice a day. Um, Sing Pass uh,
this the Singaporean government has
issued their own electronic ID. So I I I
it's not whether they're going to do it.
Uh, there's three billion people on
Earth that have access to it. What's
interesting is it's um it's not the
western world. So uh right it's it's
it's not the western world.
>> Why?
So I I I spent a lot of time in uh in
Africa in like probably 15 years ago. Um
and one of the most sort of startling
things 15 years ago in Africa was there
were no landlines. Um, right. The the
southern half of the African continent
continent pretty much skipped landlines.
Uh, they they they skipped home
internet, they skipped landlines. Uh,
and they had highquality mobile internet
uh that was much better than what was
available in the states 15 years ago in
in all parts of of of Africa. And I
think we're seeing where uh very
similarly um there's a lot of uh
economies are just skipping um you know
if if you're India for example and it's
2009 and you don't have a national
identity card do you create a physical
identity card or do you create a digital
identity
and so you know we we look at India they
just skipped uh a a national ID card and
went directly to digital
Wow. Okay. So, so it's a
fascinating.
Are there do you see big risks with this
con this this construct that linking the
electronic ID to a digital to a physical
ID in such a robust way? I mean, what
are the ways for abuse here?
>> And and and there are risks. Um and and
don't don't let anybody tell you any
different. Um so I I think there's a
couple of risks. Uh one is, you know,
you've got a government creating sort of
the ultimate honeypot.
Um
and and that is a risk. Um we've seen
where like the CPF database in Brazil
has already been breached a couple of
times. Um, and that's a you know, we've
got a every Brazilian nationals PII is
all in one place in a structured format,
>> right?
>> Um, and that that that that keeps me up
at night. Um, and I think the the other
big piece of this is um how much do you
trust your government,
>> right?
>> Because the opportunities for
surveillance, for abuse, um are are very
real. you're you're letting um this the
the government into a part of your life
that most of us have grown used to a
fair degree of anonymity in um so there
there's certainly a question about how
much do you trust your government
>> right absolutely I mean it's a then the
honeypot use case I think it's a it's a
big one from a cyber security
perspective but but I can only imagine
that given that as he starts as
centralized that then there's also a
bigger opportunities for better security
and better defensive systems. Yet, it's
it's an interesting it's an interesting
game. Um and and obviously I think
there's so much that we can talk about
in the space. We only pretty much
highlight highlighted some of the topics
um that that need to be dove into. Very
quickly, how what do you see is the role
of generative AI and deep fakes over the
next couple of years
playing out in the world of digital
identity?
I mean, I think we're just going to see
a continued acceleration. Um, like you
mentioned, you know, there was there was
much uh sort of weeping and nashing of
teeth about the US election uh and the
vulnerabilities there that that didn't
really manifest thankfully this goround.
Um, but you know, I read somewhere
recently that they estimate there's 20
developers
work using generative AI maliciously for
everyone using generative AI uh to to to
protect and defend. Um, you know, I
don't I don't know this how how accurate
that is, but it feels about right.
>> Feels feels accurate.
>> And and to me that just becomes an
inevitability. Um, so it's it's not if
uh generative AI reaches the point that
contentbased verification can no longer
be trusted, it's when um and we need to
start moving towards alternate means to
bind your digital identity uh to your
physical one and to verify it,
>> right? And I think we've seen now also
companies like World Orb, I believe by
Sam Alman also
>> coming in and playing in this game.
Daniel, one thing you're most excited
about in for the future of digital
identities.
>> So, one thing I'm most excited about and
we didn't get to talk about um is
inherent bias in a lot of the tools that
we use today.
Um so
what what I'm most excited about is uh
some of these movements towards
centralized identity verification um are
really going to help um vulnerable
populations and uh disenfranchised
people. So when you when you look at you
know the the algorithms that we use for
facial recognition when you look at the
data sets that they're trained on um
they are uh predominantly white and
male. Um so you see crazy numbers out
there like um some of the the the uh
facial verification softwares have like
a 2.3% error rate on a white man and
like a 34% error rate on a dark-skinned
woman. Um because again we're we're
utilizing workarounds
um and and those you workarounds are
trained on data sets that were scraped
from publicly available photos um which
are you know largely politicians and
government figures. So you you've got
this data set. I think the um the main
data set LFW that's used to train um uh
facial matching algorithms is like
70some percent male and 80ome% white. Um
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. I mean it's it's just
overwhelmingly biased. Uh so no matter
what kind of corrections you put in
place and fences you put in place around
an algorithm that's trained on a data
set that lopsided um you just end up
with tremendously poor performance
across um darkerkinned people uh
non-caucasian ethnicities uh and and and
women. Um so when we start talking about
moving to a more centrally managed
structured means of digital identity
verification uh you you do away with a
lot of that uh because we've no longer
got a private party that used a publicly
available data set uh to train its
algorithm. you're you're moving to um
you know like NIST has actually um
demographically
representative data sets available to
train uh facial recognition software or
algorithms. So the the removal of bias
and the introduction of equity globally
uh is is something that I am
tremendously excited about.
>> Sounds incredibly important and
incredibly impactful. Uh Daniel, I
really want to thank you for your time.
Thank you so much for just even giving
me a brief introduction into this world
of yours, which is sounds fascinating.
And uh wishing you uh you and all of us
best of luck with this with this
important endeavor. It's a it's a big
one for us. So, thank you so much.
>> Thank you, Michael. It's great to meet
you and have a great rest of your day.
>> Thank you so much.